Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir sitzen vor dem Salon.
Und wir haben eine turbulente Woche hinter uns. Die Zölle gehen rauf, dann werden sie wieder ausgesetzt, dann aber gegen China doch erhöht. China hält dagegen. Die Börsenkurse sind volatil, wie man es lange, lange nicht gesehen hat.
Hast du gekauft, als Trump dir schrieb, extra für dich die Nachricht, best time to buy oder was er geschrieben hat?
Leider nein, leider nein. Aber natürlich hat die Börse dann einen Satz nach oben gemacht, ging aber dann auch schon wieder runter. Wir wissen ja gar nicht, was jetzt gerade der Fall ist. Vielleicht ist schon alles zusammengebrochen, während wir hier noch in Ruhe sitzen. Es läuft nicht so nach Plan.
Richtig langsam zusammen.
Langsamer, ja, genau.
Ja, es läuft wirklich nicht nach Plan. Wir haben heute Textgrundlagen, die ich am Mittwoch vorbereitet habe.
Ja.
Das Ganze geschah ja am Donnerstag. Am Mittwoch habe ich mir gedacht, okay, die Leute reden jetzt immer darüber, was Trump hier so schreibt und so weiter. Man hängt sich so an kleinen, spontanen Sprechakten auf, aber es gibt ja Textgrundlage.
Wir haben diesen Maralago-Akkord, der vorherige Doktrine, wie man Weltwirtschaftspolitik macht. Amerika sieht sich ja zu Recht, erzählt man. Wie man das neu organisiert. Wir hatten vom heutigen Finanzminister zusammen mit dem heutigen Chief Economic Advisor von Trump, also zwei Posten, die durch den Senat bestätigt werden müssen, also wirklich hoch aufgehangen und wichtig, eine Art Playbook. Das ist im November 24, 30 Seiten PDF und so. Und ich habe das alles mal in sozusagen eine Textgrundlage heute gebracht, die wir auch im Salon nachher in Gänze verlinken und so. Und es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie sehr man alles, was in den Nachrichten dazu gesagt wird, hört, wenn man das einmal kennt. Weil es gibt ja durchaus einen Plan, also es folgte ja einem Plan. Und es gab eben zwei Zäsuren. Also China hat sofortige Gegenzölle gemacht, ganz wichtige Zäsur und diese Treasury Bonds. Also nicht irgendwie Europa haut sich auf die Brust und sagt, wir sind auch stark oder so, spielt alles keine Rolle, sondern es waren einfach die, funktioniert der Dollar noch.
Ganz genau. Wir sind ja hier in einer Situation, die wir schon kennen, nämlich als List Trust, manche haben schon vergessen, kurz Premierministerin war, da hatte sie die Idee, um die britische Wirtschaft anzukurbeln, müsse man nur wieder den Superreichen noch mehr Steuerlasten abnehmen. Und darauf haben ja auch die Märkte genauso reagiert, nämlich die Staatsanleihen plötzlich sind nicht mehr so beliebt. Man muss also eine Risikoprämie aufschlagen. Das heißt, die Zinsen für die britische Staatsanleihen steigen. Das bedeutet, die Verschuldung der Briten wird teurer dadurch, da die diese Zinsen ja auch dann bedienen müssen. Und bedeutet vor allem, dass man das also nicht mehr als einen sicheren Hafen betrachtet, britische Staatsanleihen zu haben. Genau das haben wir jetzt in Amerika wieder. Dass nun Trump mit seiner verrückten Zollpolitik dafür sorgt, dass plötzlich die Märkte sagen, wir brauchen da mal so eine Idiotenprämie. Das müsste ein bisschen teurer sein. Denn so sicher ist dieser Hafen, amerikanische Staatsanleihen, plötzlich uns nicht mehr. Und dann geschieht genau das und plötzlich muss also Trump darauf reagieren. Und da sieht man wieder, wie sehr dann jemand, der eigentlich glaubt, er sei jetzt der Präsent, er kann machen, was er will, die Hände gebunden werden durch die Macht des Marktes.
Absolut. Also, dass Trump diese Zölle plötzlich alle zurücknahm, bis auf China, war eine totale Panikreaktion. Das wusste er selber nicht vorher. Dann haben ihm nicht nur seine eigenen Leute, sondern dann haben auch die Banken angerufen und gesagt, das sind die Kennziffern. Du kannst so und so viel von der FED fordern. Und wir haben sozusagen zwei Leitzinsen. Das eine ist eher politisch gemachte. John Powell sagt irgendwas. Und das andere ist eben der, der am Markt entsteht. Und dann haben vorher alle gedacht, naja, der Warren Buffett wird sich ja wohl nicht so geirrt haben, wenn er da nur noch in T-Bonds geht und so. Er hat ja irgendwie 250 Milliarden Cash angehäuft und alle so, der vertraut den Aktien nicht, der geht in die Staatsanleihe. Und dann, als es drauf ankam, nee, doch nicht. Die Strategie hat sich für ihn ausgezahlt, weil er sozusagen vor dem Börsencrash alles umgelagert hatte, aber darin liegt keine Losung. Und diese Staatsanleihen Amerikas, also der Preis für die gesteuert, oder Folge der Nachfrage nach ihnen, steuert halt extrem viel. Da hängen einfach so viele andere Zinsentscheidungen dran und so, dass das, also als Trump da so steigend und meinte, ja, hier haben so manche Leute kalte Füße gekriegt und so, hat er von sich selbst geredet.
Ja, ja, um das...
Hat ihn selbst überrascht, dass er das...
Um das auch mal runterzubrechen für die Leute, die jetzt da nicht so tief drin sind, es ist ja ganz einfach zu verstehen. Also Zinsen sind ja quasi eine Risikoprämie. Das heißt, wenn man irgendetwas mit hohen Zinsen hat, dann ist das Risiko auch relativ hoch. Also man kann natürlich auch in Staatsanleihen von Schwellenländern zum Beispiel sein Geld investieren. Da kann man sehr gute Zinsen bekommen, aber es ist das Risiko auch sehr hoch, dass damit dann plötzlich das Geld futsch ist, dass das kein sicherer Hafen ist. Und genau das ist eben hier der Fall, wenn man eine solche sehr frei drehende Politik hat, dass dann das nicht mehr als ein solch sicherer Hafen angesehen wird. Und ich habe in diesen Tagen aber auch nochmal viel über Elon Musk nachgedacht, der ja auch außer sich ist und diese Zollpolitik und so weiter nicht gut findet. Wenn man sich ja mal ansieht, was Joe Biden gemacht hat, dann war das ja ein Inflation Reduction Act, in Klammern, für Elon Musk.
Ja, absolut.
Das war ein Akt, der die E-Mobilität vorantreiben würde, die die amerikanische Wirtschaft stärken würde, die die Konsumenten stärkt mit höheren Löhnen. Das heißt, die können sich auf meinen Tesla leisten. Und es ist generell eine Richtung, die sagt, wir müssen mehr auf E-Mobilität gehen. Das ist ganz klar die Richtung gewesen. Plus, er ist als ein doch politischer Falke immer wieder zu erkennen gewesen, dann Biden, der ja sagt, wir brauchen eine Absicherung gegen China, wir brauchen mehr Rüstung. Er war jemand, der sagte, auch die Satelliten sind vor uns wahnsinnig, auch da müssen wir hegomonial bleiben. Also all das, was Elon Musk auch noch bedient. Und reine Ideologie, anders kann man es sich ja nicht erklären, hat Elon Musk ins falsche Lager getrieben. Genau. Denn, wenn man jetzt ökonomisch rational denken würde, dann hätte man als Elon Musk gesagt, mir ist völlig egal, was die Demokraten für eine Vokopolitik machen oder einfordern. Wenn die wollen, dass ich ab morgen die Leute mit Kuckuck und die IA begrüße, dann mache ich auch das. Denn meinem Unternehmen, meinen vielen Unternehmen nutzt es, dass diese Politik von beiden betrieben wird. Und stattdessen ist jetzt Trump gelaufen, der genau das alles jetzt gerade zerschlägt. Das kann sich natürlich auf Dauer noch mal ändern, aber momentan sieht es eher gruselig aus.
Also gerade Tesla, ich habe das hier mal markiert, mit Farben, der Tesla-Cos in der Trump- und in der Biden-Zeit.
Ah ja.
Unter Trump, der Tesla-Cos liegt irgendwo so bei knapp über 50 oder 40 oder so. Trump kommt ins Amt 2016, Trump geht aus dem Amt und der Tesla-Cos liegt so bei 50 oder 60, kann es gar nicht so genau erkennen, es ist so knapp über der Null-Linie. Dann kommt Biden und das Ding geht zehnfach nach oben. Also unter Joe Biden, und zwar schon nach anderthalb Jahren, Tesla-Cos 400 Dollar pro Aktie. Das ist einfach eine Verzehnfachung seines Vermögens. Damit wurde Elon Musk zum reichsten Menschen des Planeten und in der Geschichte so wahrscheinlich. Dann bleibt er da oben und dann wird Donald Trump Präsident und das ganze Ding stürzt wieder in sich zusammen. Die Pointe ist einfach, und es geht ja nicht nur für Tesla, hätten die Superreichen in Amerika gesagt, wir wollen, dass weiter ein Demokrat regiert und wir sind sogar bereit, 20% pauschale Vermögenssteuer auf unsere Vermögen zu zahlen, hätte sich das für alle ausgezahlt. Die wären reicher als heute unter Trump. Und die Gesellschaft hätte auch noch was davon von dieser Vermögensabschätzung. Stattdessen sind die ärmer geworden. Das Geld wurde einfach vernichtet. Buchwerde, die weggeflogen sind. Und es wird ja jetzt wieder weiter runtergehen. Das war ja nur so ein, bis alle gesehen haben, ach so auf China bleibt's, sorry. Also 10 Billionen, 1 Billion plus ist doch sinnlos. Und jetzt ist blöd für alle. Wir haben einen Culture Bar. Wir haben die Ärmsten der Gesellschaft nicht durchfinanziert. Und die Reichen sind trotzdem ärmer. Das ist ja absurd. Also die Realität ist so dumm, dass ich mittlerweile denke, Demokratie, schön und gut. Aber wenn wir es auslosen würden, wer die Mandate bekommt, wäre die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher, dass dort kluge Leute sitzen. Also durch diesen demokratischen Prozess, wie wir ihn jetzt haben, mit diesem Wahlkampf, wie wir ihn hatten, ist eine der dümmst möglichen Optionen Präsident geworden.
Ja, das muss man ja auch nochmal sehen. Trump ist ja damals mit einer Administration in seiner ersten Amtszeit gestartet, die sich durchaus sehen lassen konnte. Nicht durch die Bank, aber da waren ja durchaus erfahrene Leute dabei und die wussten auch ein bisschen, wie zum Beispiel Kapitalmärkte funktionieren und warum Zölle nicht grundsätzlich gut sein können.
Die haben schon morgens mal Bescheid gesagt und nicht erst 5.12 Uhr mit der Nacht, wie es ist.
Und die wussten das auch, die haben es auch verstanden. Nun hat Trump gesehen, dass die ihm aber mit unter die Hände gebunden haben, weil sie ihm dann immer darauf verwiesen, na, das geht so nicht, Mr. President. Davon wollte er sich jetzt losmachen und hat jetzt diese Knallchargen an seiner Seite, die mal heute dies, morgen das sagen, aber dort ist es nicht mehr so durchdacht, bis dann irgendwann wieder jemand von der FED kommen muss und sagen muss, also, es geht doch nicht so, wir müssen da jetzt mit dieser Zollpolitik mal kurzfristig zumindest aufhören. Also das ist ja interessant, dass es also die verbliebenen Experten sind, also einfach die Funktionäre in einem technokratischen System, die noch nicht ausgetauscht werden konnten, die jetzt gerade Trump noch mal den Arsch gerettet haben. Das ist eine wirklich gruselige Situation.
Also wir kommen halt auf die Textgrundlage zu sprechen, um zumindest die inhärente Logik dessen, was da geplant war, mal zu würdigen. Also man kann es schon würdigen. Ich habe einen Text von Yanis Varoufakis dabei, der meinte, das ist schon riskant, das zu machen, aber es ist auch nicht völlig blöde aus so einer amerikanischen Sicht, dass man so einen Hegemon neu aufstellen möchte, weil man sieht, es ging ja einiges flöten, warum werden alle iPhones in China hergestellt und so.
Ja.
Aber gut.
Genau, darüber müssen wir unbedingt mal diskutieren, denn es ist vielleicht nicht nur irrational, sondern es gibt nochmal eine ganz andere Idee davon. Aber die ist auch sehr langfristig dann nur zu verstehen. Und das ist interessant, dass ein so uralter Präsident ein dann so langfristiges Projekt verfolgen würde.
Ja, aber das ist genau der Punkt. Das politische Ziel ist ohne Frage richtig. Nur die Zeit, die man dafür braucht. Und ich möchte daran erinnern, wir haben in Deutschland einen Wirtschaftsminister gehabt, dem wir unterstellen, dass er einerseits klug ist und auf der anderen Seite sich hat beraten lassen und so weiter und so fort. Und trotzdem gab es das auch bei Robert Habeck an diesem Heizungsgesetz, dass er sah, wir haben einen Krieg durch Putin, ab jetzt weniger Gas in Deutschland, wir müssen sofort alle Heizungen austauschen. Und dann hat man ihm gesagt, ne, du kannst nicht in den nächsten drei Jahren alle Heizungen austauschen, das wäre ein 50 Jahre Projekt. Und ja, also diese Verwirrung kommt immer wieder, weil man in charge nicht genau abschätzen können, wie groß das Reich ist, das sie regieren. Das ist eben nicht nur Washington DC oder die Berliner Blase ist, sondern ganz Deutschland, ganz Amerika, die ganze Welt. Und das habe ich auf den Heuwerten gesagt, man unterschätzt das, wie groß das immer ist. Wie viel das, man fährt stundenlang Zug, man fliegt tagelang mit dem Flugzeug, und man hat trotzdem noch nicht alles erreicht. Man unterschätzt immer wieder, wie groß diese Gesellschaft ist und wie träge und überhaupt. Und das ist jetzt Trump-basiert, das ist Robert Habeck-basiert. Es scheint so ein Ding zu sein, dass man, wie sollte man auch regieren, wenn man es wirklich abschätzen kann, in welcher Reichweite das so ist. Also schwierig.
Lass uns noch über die Schulden reden. Das ist ja ein Problem für Trump. Er will geringere Staatsschulden eigentlich haben. Das soll ja auch ein Grund sein für seine Zollpolitik. Nun sind wir ja im Podcast, in dem immer wieder gesagt wird, naja, ein Staat ist ja nicht wie ein Privathaushalt, der kann sich ja immer weiter verschulden. Und das stimmt natürlich erst einmal deshalb, weil der Staat so ein Ewigkeitsversprechen hat, ja, der Staat geht immer weiter. Und es ist nicht wie unser Leben, das endlich ist, sondern eigentlich kann der Staat da auf eine unendliche Perspektive hinauslaufen. Und zugleich ist es ja auch so, dass Investitionen durch mehr Schulden möglich sind. Das heißt, die Vermögensberge wachsen, nicht nur die Schuldenberge wachsen. Bei der Aufrüstung ist es anders. Und ich glaube, dass das gerade in der Öffentlichkeit sehr vermixed wird. Und das sorgt für eigentlich ein falsches Denken. Nämlich das, was jetzt im Zuge der Aufrüstungsdebatte und der Schuldenregeländerungen passiert, ist nicht in dem Sinne MMT, wie das mal gedacht wurde. Nämlich da ging es ja schon auch darum, dass diese Staatsausgaben wiederum mehr Wirtschaftswachstum generieren. Und ich habe einen Podcast gehört von der Böckler-Stiftung Systemrelevant von Sebastian Dulin. Und Sebastian Dulin ist ja ein sehr anerkanter Ökonom und der spricht, ich empfehle das komplett zu hören, aber der spricht nicht nur über die Wirtschaftsprognose für Deutschland. Es sieht nicht so toll aus erst einmal im nächsten Jahr, vielleicht besser. Aber er spricht auch über die Aufrüstung und sagt Folgendes.
Auch zum Teil Eurokosten, ja klar. Man muss sich ganz klar machen, dass diese geopolitische Entwicklung, die wir haben, auch wenn jetzt das Wirtschaftswachstum anzieht, aber dass die einfach uns Wohlstand kosten wird. Weil einerseits geben wir mehr für Verteidigung aus und Verteidigungsausgaben sind nun mal, das ist verlorenes Geld in dem Sinne. Wenn wir eine Welt hätten, wo keiner Verteidigungsausgaben oder Rüstungsausgaben machen würde, dann ging es uns allen besser.
Verlorenes Geld, sagt er da. Das finde ich sehr interessant. Weiter sagt er über die Entglobalisierung, die droht.
Bestimmte Vorteile der Globalisierung zurückdrehen, weil wir eigene Lieferketten haben möchten, die resilienter sind. In der Summe werden wir dadurch ärmer. Insbesondere in einem Land wie Deutschland wird er ein bisschen ärmer, weil wir so stark auf die Globalisierung gesetzt hatten.
Diese ganze Rede von der resilienten Lieferkette bedeutet natürlich auch, dass das eine Lieferkette ist, die, um resilienter zu sein, teurer ist. Das heißt, das sind einfach zusätzliche Kosten, die aufkommen. Das wäre so, wenn man sagt, ich muss eigentlich immer noch diesen Weg von A nach B gehen, um meine Ware zu exportieren. Aber plötzlich ist dieser Weg dreimal so teuer geworden, weil der ja noch eine besondere Sicherheitsvorkehrung hat.
Ja, also die Verteidigungskosten, also das Argument pauschal ist richtig. Ich unterstütze das total. Ich halte es auch für eine große Geldverschwendung. Aber so, wie wir es jetzt in Deutschland konzipieren, dass der Verteidigungsbegriff auch so diese Katastrophenvorsorge und so weiter, also so zivile Einrichtungen und wir haben ja aus, du hast ja damals diese Bunker gespielt, dass da in Skandinavien die Bunker unterirdisch auch als Turnhallen genutzt werden. Also wir haben es durchaus mit Infrastruktur zu tun oder könnten es zu tun haben, die sich auch zivil nutzen lässt und auszahlt. Plus, im Koalitionsvertrag wird ja sehr darauf abgestellt, dass das nicht nur Investitionen in Socken für Soldaten ist, sondern auch Technik. Und das israelische Modell, das ganz nah an die Universitäten ranrückt, ganz nah an diese Forschungsdinger und so weiter, da ist dann auch schon ein volkswirtschaftliches Win-Win drin, dass es ohne diesen Treiber, wir dort ja eine konkrete Landesverteidigung organisieren, wir brauchen also diese Art von Fortschritt und er lässt sich aber auch anders nutzen, mal gucken, was da passiert.
Naja, das israelische Vorbild bedeutet aber, dass man wahnsinnig viel exportiert. Also Israel macht das ja nicht nur für sich, sondern man müsste dann sehr viel mehr Waffen exportieren.
Ja, aber wir sind ja auch auf Platz 5.
Jaja, nur man fragt sich, man müsste es sehr deutlich steigern, wenn man jetzt die Rüstungsausgaben verdoppelt, müsste man ja den Export mehr als verdoppeln, um das rein zu bekommen. Und man fragt sich an, wen will man da eigentlich Waffen liefern? Also da gibt es ja jetzt, wir können ja jetzt vielleicht sagen, wir liefern den Russen Waffen.
Ja genau, aber wir haben ja auch viel Dual-Use-Technik, also das Starlink.
Ja okay, Starlink. Aber Panzer und all diese ganzen Sachen nicht.
Deswegen ja. Ich habe ja schon von Anfang an gesagt, seit drei Jahren, dass wir als Sehgewohnheit bei Krieg wieder die Panzerschlacht sehen, ist ja total daneben.
Jaja, man macht viel mit Drohnen jetzt.
Genau.
Aber auch das sind keine Investitionen.
Das sieht man aber nicht ganz so in den Zahlen zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt, weil zum Beispiel, wenn wir mehr Panzer kaufen und mehr Soldaten in der Kaserne haben, per se ist das ja alles Bruttoinlandsprodukt. Das sind ja Staatsausgaben. Das ist aber Bruttoinlandsprodukt, was eben den direkten Wohlstand nicht erhöhen.
Ja, das bedeutet also BIP-Steigerung bedeutet ja nicht Wohlstandssteigerung. Das hat man ja im Zuge der Debatten um Klima und Investitionen schon gehabt. Und hier zeigt sich das natürlich in aller Deutlichkeit, dass das ja nicht unseren Wohlstand erhöht, aber das BIP möglicherweise erhöhen kann. Und dann kann man das als ein tolles Erfolgserlebnis feiern, ist aber keins.
Deswegen, ich habe gestern Karlsruher auch wieder damit gescherzt, können natürlich jetzt immer größere Autos bauen, die wir in mehr Unfälle verwickeln. Das ist mehr BIP.
Ja.
Oder halt einfach alle Dienstleistungen, die in Familien so stattfindet, wird ins BIP eingerechnet, aber auch mehr. Jaja, können wir locker von 4 auf 5 Billionen gehen im Jahr.
Ich meine, langfristig, wenn wir dauerhaft jetzt mehr Geld für Rüstung ausgeben wollen, wenn das die Entscheidung ist, oder wir das für notwendig erachten, dann muss das von irgendjemandem bezahlt werden. Man kann natürlich sagen, im Moment können wir sowohl mehr Kredite aufnehmen für ein bisschen mehr Verteidigung und für mehr Investitionen. Das geht alles von der Schuldentragfähigkeit her. Aber am Ende hätte man vielleicht dann doch auch mehr für Investitionen machen können, weniger für Rüstung.
Ja, das bedeutet, wenn jetzt stärker investiert wird in die Rüstung, dann ist das keine Investition. Man kann das jetzt mal kursfristig so machen. Und die Kapitalmärkte sind uns ja nicht böse. Gegenteil, Staatsanleihen sind beliebt. Wenn wir jetzt aber signalisieren, dass das auf Dauer so laufen soll, dass das über Schulden läuft, werden die Kapitalmärkte dann nicht mitspielen und sie werden Deutschland abstrafen dafür. Weil sie sagen, ihr mögt damit vielleicht noch künstlich das BIP erhöhen. Aber das sind ja alles Dinge, die ihr produziert, die ihr im besten Fall gar nie einsetzen werdet. Im schlechtesten Fall gibt es einen Krieg. Es gibt ja eigentlich nur diese beiden Optionen und ein bisschen kann man noch exportieren. Und da sind wir dann schon an einem Punkt, wo also die Überschuldung ein Problem werden kann und wo uns auch eine MMT nicht mehr hilft.
Ja, es sei denn, man sieht diese Aufrüstung nur als ein Baustein in der neuen hegemonialen Weltpolitik, in der man die benutzt, um handelsfähige Wege freizuschießen und gleichzeitig noch den Euro anstelle des Dollar als neue Reservewährung installiert. Diese eine Pointe, die kann ich ja mal wegziehen, weil die auch aus meinem Kopf nicht mehr rausgeht. Dieser Chief Economic Advisor steht einfach im weißen Haushalt zu einer Rede und sagt dann, das Bild ist ja ganz klar, wir haben auf der Welt sehr gute wirtschaftliche Beziehung zwischen Brasilien und China. Wie ist das eigentlich möglich? Dann erklärt er, die einen zahlen das Geld an die anderen, welches Geld? Dollar. Die Brasilianer trauen den Chinesen nicht über den Weg, die nicht den. Also sagen sie einfach, neutraler Grund und Boden, wir nehmen den Dollar. So, die Ware ist bezahlt, jetzt muss sie transportiert werden. Was macht Amerika? Schießt den Suezkanal frei. Bompt die Huties zurück in die Steinzeit, damit im Suezkanal der Container einfach durchtransportiert werden kann. Das heißt, wenn man diese grandiose Verschuldung macht, noch schafft das Europa nicht. Aber Amerika hat das eben geschafft, indem sie gesagt haben, naja, aber die ganze Welt ist ja darauf angewiesen, dass wir so verschuldet sind, weil wir eben diese zwei großen Dienstleistungen, eine Währung, auf die sich alle einigen können und freigeschossene Seewege zur Verfügung stellen. Und dann kann man so eine Verschuldung machen.
Genau, aber du glaubst ja jetzt nicht ernsthaft und wünschst es dir nicht, dass Europa zu einem Imperium wird, dass jetzt in dieser Weise imperialistisch die Welt sich strukturiert.
Naja, das was jetzt passiert ist, ist eben, dass die Chinesen sagen, sorry Amerika, wir können unsere Seewege selber freischießen. Ja. Und dann wird die Verschuldung Amerikas plötzlich ein Problem, weil sie nicht mehr gerechtfertigt ist.
Aber dass Europa jetzt an die Stelle von Amerika gesetzt wird, davon gehst du ja nicht aus. Naja, aber entschuldigung mal. Guck dich mal bitte unsere Volkswirtschaften an.
Ja, aber du hast ja Lage der Nation gehört. Irgendwer wird die Huttis in der Steinzeit zu Brückbomben wollen.
Ja, das sind die Großmachts-Fantasien von verrückten Europäern. Jaja, nur glaube ich, dass das auch dauern sich immer nicht auszahlt. Ja, es beginnt immer mit einer Fantasie. Deswegen spiele ich diese Clips hier, um nochmal eindeutig zu wahren. So einfacher ist das nicht, so wir nehmen mal mehr Schulden auf und so. Und zur Not bompen wir uns alles frei. Hier nochmal Dulin.
Genau, das ist der Punkt. Wenn man die jetzt wirklich tatsächlich auf einem Niveau von 3, 3,5% des Produzenten und Inlandsproduktes hochziehen wollen würde und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob wir das brauchen oder wollen oder wie auch immer, das ist jetzt eine rein makroökonomische Aussage, dann wird das nicht einfach durch mehr Verschuldung funktionieren, sondern da muss man sich fragen, wer das am Ende bezahlt.
Ja, Dolin sagt dann, man könnte ja die Reichen besteuern, aber da wissen wir ja alle, das wird nicht passieren, sondern das wird irgendwie anders passieren. Und ich hörte dann einen Bericht von, ich glaube ARD war das, in dem Kiesewetter zu Wort kam und der macht da schon eine interessante Verbindung. Also einmal Thema Urlaubstage und Thema Flugzeugträger. Wie passt das zusammen? Und wir haben jetzt noch Dolin im Kopf. Nein, wir haben jetzt noch Dolin im Kopf, der sagt, ja, das muss dann schon irgendwie bezahlt werden.
Wir sagen uns auch sehr deutlich, in Amerika haben die Arbeiter im Schnitt zwölf Tage Urlaub, bei uns 30. Die Amerikaner finanzieren elf Flugzeugträger. Die Europäer haben, glaube ich, die Franzosen ein und die Briten ein. Also sind gar keine Relationen. Die Amerikaner erwarten von uns deutlich mehr Engagement.
Wie geht das zusammen? Also was er uns da eigentlich sagt, ist ja, wenn wir jetzt auf Urlaubstage verzichten würden, und das war ja auch wieder bei links-siberalen Journalisten wie Bernd Ulrich schon zu lesen, wir müssen Feiertage opfern, dann, wenn wir also mehr arbeiten, dann steigern wir tatsächlich unseren Wohlstand, mit dem wir dann mehr Flugzeugträger finanzieren können. Das heißt also, die Aufrüstung, die hier vorgeschlagen wird, findet natürlich auf dem Rücken der arbeitenden Bevölkerung statt. Die soll nämlich die zusätzliche Verschuldung irgendwie wieder reinarbeiten, damit die Kapitalmärkte sehen, ah, okay, die rüsten nicht nur auf, sondern die arbeiten jetzt auch mehr. Die Ausbeutung nimmt also zu, dann können wir beruhigt sein, da müssen wir auch nicht höhere Zinsen auf europäische Staatsanleihen verlangen.
Also den Kiesewetter kann man jetzt ganz einfach auskontern, mit der Erfahrung dieser Woche, in dem man sagt, ja, Herr Kiesewetter, Sie haben recht, die Amerikaner sagen seit 20 Jahren, wir sollen mehr für uns die Verteidigung zahlen. Nur, das wollen die Amerikaner nicht wirklich. Denn eine militärische Hoheit zu behalten, ist denen schon ganz wichtig. Die gehen ja auch nicht nach China und sagen, könnt ihr bitte mal zehn Flugzeugträger kaufen.
Ja.
So.
Was die Amerikaner eigentlich wollen, ist selber diese Flugzeugträger kaufen, betreiben und so weiter, egal was es kostet. Aber dafür, liebe Europäer, akzeptiert ihr bitte diesen Zoll. Der ist nämlich reziprog von Amerika ausgedacht. Nicht die Vergeltung, dass wir Gegenzölle machen, ist reziprog auf Augenhöhe, sondern die Amerikaner fühlen sich bisher verkauft. Sie kriegen alles, was wir liefern, umsonst. Und dann deindustrialisieren sie uns noch. Deswegen diese Zölle, die von vornherein als reziprog, das ist jetzt das Preisschild für, wir haben diese Flugzeugträger. Und da könnte man Kiesewetter jetzt fragen. Herr Kiesewetter, wenn ihnen diese Partnerschaft mit Amerika so wichtig ist und die Verteidigung und so weiter, dass sie hier so westlicher Hegemon bleiben, dann müssen sie diesen Zoll akzeptieren. Aber was wir gesehen haben, ist, dass die Europäer, die Chinesen haben es natürlich sehr clever gemacht. Das war sozusagen ein Gegenschlag wie bei der Atomwaffe. Es wird registriert, sie ist oben zack gegen Zölle hoch. Also wurde nicht mal intern darüber geredet. Die Europäer haben noch fünf Tage gebraucht, bis sie gesagt haben, okay, wir machen das auch. Dann haben sie sie ausgesetzt und die Europäer so, wir setzen sie für 90 Tage aus. Also wenn Kiesewetter einen Beitrag leisten möchte, der den Amerikanern total entgegenkommt, dann sagt er von allein, bitte nicht gegen Zölle machen, sondern den Preisaufschlag Amerikas jetzt akzeptieren. Da wird es aber nicht bereit.
Ob das geschehen wird, das glauben wir eher mal nicht. Sag noch kurz, ich hatte bei Instagram gesehen, dass du im Schauspielhaus warst. Wir gehen ja immer nur in die Oper. Wir waren einmal im Schauspielhaus und sind dann gegangen, waren ganz erzürnt, das ist doch nicht Shakespeare. Du hast dir einen Klassiker vorgenommen, Faust. Wie war es?
Ich hatte keinen Ansehen, noch mal ins Theater zu gehen. Ich wollte ihm eigentlich keine Chance geben. Dann war ich ja in Hamburg in diesem The Circle und es war spektakulär. Also habe ich gedacht und es war auch spektakulär, weil es quasi fast ohne Kulisse nur Text und so. Und die Textgrundlage von Dave Eggers ist ja gut, sehr gut, zehn Jahre alt, also auch gut abgehangen. Die Realität hat sie eingeholt. Also es war sozusagen ein perfektes Theater. Also habe ich mir gedacht, Faust läuft. Ich habe Faust noch nie im Theater gesehen. Ich kenne natürlich Gründkönze bei YouTube und so, aber ich wollte es sehen. Ich wollte es vor allem hören. Und ich dachte, die werden doch wohl jetzt nicht bei Goethe und Föllefanz machen, oder? Die können doch mal, wie in der Oper, Texttreue, Musiktreue, die Inszenierung spielt woanders und so weiter. Also gehe ich ins Theater. Faust 1 und 2. So, Faust 1.
Wie lange sollte das dann gehen?
Vier und halb Stunden. Faust 1 wurde in 25 Minuten abgehandelt. Das Best of der Zitate, einfach durchgenudelt. Keine Zuordnung von Sprecher und Schauspieler, sondern irgendwer hat irgendwas gesagt. Das Ding wurde hauptsächlich hinter der Kulisse in so einer Geisterbahn aufgeführt. Man war also nur über Video beteiligt. Und nach 25 Minuten hieß es Pause. Wir so, ja mir ist noch nicht so nach Pause, ich kann hier sitzen bleiben. Plötzlich, bitte verlassen sie alle den Saal. Also mussten wir alle raus. Ich habe schon gedacht. Nee, das war jetzt Faust 1. Ich wollte eigentlich wirklich mal alles sehen und ich kann es nicht akzeptieren, dass zum Beispiel der Gott und Mephisto am Anfang in Personalunion gesprochen wird. Also das ein Schauspiel auf der Bühne ist der beides Spiel. Das geht nicht. Also das ist nicht die Idee. Die Idee war der große Gott mit seinen Engeln und unten der kleine Mephisto, der versucht da so ein bisschen mitzuspielen. Aber das kann man nicht in Personalunion machen. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht. So, okay, Pause. Dann Faust 2 in zwei Teilen. Den ersten Teil habe ich gesehen, dann bin ich rausgegangen. Faust 2 beginnt damit, dass man in Reihe 3, also ich in Reihe 3, vor einer riesigen Leinwand, die ganze Bühnenfront war mit einer Leinwand zugehangen, wie so ein Bett lagen, auf dem in voller Größe ein Film projiziert wurde für eine Viertelstunde oder so. Dieser Film spielte mit den Schauspielern vor dem Theater auf dem Willy-Brandt-Platz an der Bahnhaltestelle.
Kriegt toll.
Noch mit Fischauge gefilmt. Und ich saß unten rechts in der Ecke, Platz 33 oder so. Also ich hab Kopfschmerzen gekriegt. Und ich dachte auch, ich bin ja nicht im Kino. Ich wollte Theater, ich wollte Text und so weiter. Dass das Wort Ficken, Arschloch und Frankfurt in dem Goethe vorkommen soll, keine Ahnung, wo er das alles total erschraubt. Dass dann außer das Ensemble-Mitglied plötzlich nackt über die Bühne rennen muss, Standard, bei voller Beleuchtung. Dass Faust von eigentlich niemandem gespielt wird, sondern so eine Puppe darstellt mit relativ wenig Text. Und wenn Text, irgendein Schauspieler klemmt gerade hinter der Puppe und spricht in diesen Styropor-Kopf rein, man versteht nichts, es wird andauernd rumgebrüllt. Helena ist plötzlich gar kein antiges Mysterium mehr, sondern ein Roboter an Seiburg. Also die Liste wäre unendlich weiter zu viel. Es war nicht zu vertragen, wirklich nicht zu vertragen. Ich hätte alles vertragen, wenn die Text treue geblieben wäre. Aber es war so schlimm. So, dann gehen wir raus. Und zeitgleich läuft die letzte Vorführung Le Postillon, Dingsda Bums. Wir gehen also aus dem Theater raus und hören Monika. Wird ja immer nach draußen übertragen.
Man muss sagen, das ist eine Sängerin aus dem Ortsraumpel.
Die beste Sängerin der Welt. Also das ist wirklich die Beste. Wir gehen also aus dem Theater raus, stehen vor diesem blechernen Lautsprecher der Oper und lassen noch eine Band fahren, weil es gerade so schön ist. Das ist mein Schauspielerlebnis jetzt wieder gewesen. Und ich möchte eine Zäsur markieren, denn ich habe ja auch Adolescence gesehen. Und in diesem Monat hat das Fernsehen das Theater überholt. Also was Wahrhaftigkeit und überhaupt angeht und so, kriegt man im Fernsehen mehr geboten. Wir sagen ja immer, wir gehen in die Oper, weil dort Medien unvermittelt, der Ton, wie er aus den Instrumenten kommt, da wird in den Saal reingesungen, ohne Mikrofon und so weiter und so fort. Also Adolescence kam näher ran als Faust. Also dieser Faust hier in Frankfurt. Wirklich beeindruckend, muss man sagen.
Wir bleiben bei der Kultur, nämlich wir sprechen jetzt im Salon über ein hochinteressantes Buch über Spotify. Sehr viele, die uns hier hören, hören uns über Spotify. Die meisten Leute hören Musik über Spotify. Und generell ist die Spotifyisierung, wenn man es mal so sagen möchte, weit fortgeschritten. Also auch die, die nicht bei Spotify sind, sind die ganze Zeit von Spotify in irgendeiner Weise doch beherrscht. Denn Spotify hat die Musik verändert. Und jetzt haben natürlich alle schon mal gehört, ja, da wird ja mit Algorithmen, mit Daten und so weiter gearbeitet. Hier gehen wir einmal ganz tief rein, wie weitreichend das ist. Es hat mich schockiert, muss ich sagen. Ich hätte es nicht gedacht, auch wenn ich schon vieles angenommen habe. Aber das ist doch noch mal eine Dimension, die mir so nicht klar war. Das Buch heißt Mood Machine, The Rise of Spotify and the Cost of the Perfect Playlist von Liz Pelly. Sie hat sich zehn Jahre lang mit Spotify auseinandergesetzt. Und das Resultat ist jetzt dieses Buch, über das wir sprechen werden.
Ja, es ist so, das Buch arbeitet auch ein bisschen gegen mich, denn diese Playlist ist mir aufgefallen. Ich habe nur eine Playlist und das ist die von Liedern, die ich selbst zusammengestellt habe. Und ich fange eigentlich immer nur die ersten zehn anzuhören und ist dann so eine Dauerschleife. Und dann kommt alle drei Monate mal eins dazu, so ungefähr. Aber ich scheine da nicht Hauptlastträger des Erfolgs von Spotify zu sein, sondern die Leute hören anders. Das finde ich ganz erstaunlich. Wir haben ein ganz tolles Kapitel am Ende über die Bibliotheken. Das hätte ich gerne früher gehabt, wie auch immer. Also wirklich sehr beeindruckend. Und wir haben wieder das Thema hier zu tun, bei dem man sich jetzt fragt, hä, aber ist nicht gerade Zoll und Trump und Koalitionsvertrag? Wieso reden die jetzt im Salon zwei Stunden über Spotify? Und ich möchte jedem, der diesen Podcast jetzt hört, nochmal dran erinnern an das eigene Nutzungsverhalten. Selbst in der höchsten, krassesten Nachrichtenlage, in der wir hören, irgendwelche Milliardäre haben durch Insider-Trading 10 Billionen Dollar verdient oder sowas. Also zwei Corona-Lockdowns innerhalb von fünf Minuten eingecashed einfach. Koalitionsvertrag ist fertig. Ein neuer Kanzler wird gewählt. Selbst an solchen Nachrichtentagen verbringen wir mehr Zeit mit Musik und Spotify, als mit Nachrichtenkonsum. Ist meine Vermutung. Bei mir ist es auf jeden Fall so. Ich höre immer eine Stunde mehr Musik am Tag wahrscheinlich als irgendwelche Podcasts. Wo ich sehr viel Podcasts höre, aber dann hört man, wie viel Musik ich höre.
Wer sagt, das ist nicht mein Vibe, oder der sagt, ich bin gerade irgendwie in einem anderen Mood und und und, ist schon von Spotify beeinflusst. Also der Vibe ist ein Begriff, der von Spotify stark gemacht wird, nämlich wenn es um diese Playlisten geht. Also das heißt, alles, was uns eigentlich so durchdringt, ist permanent da mit Spotify, mit Netflix. Da kann man auch einige Parallelen natürlich ziehen. Also man erfährt sehr viel über die Kulturindustrie heute. Und wir etappen uns eben genau dabei, dass wir ja auch plötzlich merken, ach ja, das war so ein Sound, der ist mir damals aufgefallen. Der hat mir auch eigentlich gefallen, aber wo kommt das dann her? Also was hat dazu geführt, dass dieser Sound produziert wurde? Und das können wir hier sehen. Und das geht dann auch bis hin zu Künstlern wie Billie Eilish, wo ja auch immer so das Märchen erzählt wird, die sich da mit ihrem Bruder zusammengeschlossen hat, um ganz andere Musik zu machen. Und plötzlich merkt man, wie plattformgetrieben das alles war. Also wirklich ein Buch, über das wir jetzt ausführlich diskutieren müssen. Des Weiteren stelle ich vor den neuen Roman von Christian Kracht. Er, das ist ja ein Autor, an dem man, wenn man sich mit deutscher Literatur oder Gegenwart beschäftigt, nicht vorbeikommt. Hat der gar kein Name drauf? Doch, doch.
Hat der kein Name?
Doch, Christian Kracht. Er.
Ach, er.
Er heißt das und wir müssen auch schon klären, was überhaupt mit diesem Titel gemeint ist. Dann hat Thomas Wagner ein Buch vorgelegt, das trägt den Titel Abenteuer der Moderne, die großen Jahre der Soziologie. Was ist das? Ist das einfach ein Einführungsband? 1949 bis 1669. Also, um das deutlich zu sagen, vor Luhmann, ja, also die Luhmann-Zeit beginnt dann auch.
Vor den Unis und so.
Ich kann dir sagen, Luhmann kommt auch noch kurz vor, werde dir eine schöne Anekdote vorlegen. Hier geht es aber um eigentlich zwei Antipoten, nämlich Arnold Gehlen und Theodor W. Adorno. Und wie diese schwierige Beziehung dann zu einer freundschaftlichen Beziehung wird. Und es ist zugleich auch die Geschichte der Soziologie und der jungen Bundesrepublik. Ein ganz, ganz erstaunliches Buch. Dann dein großes Thema, wir brauchen Atombomben.
Ja.
Nein, sagt Olaf L. Müller, ein Philosoph der analytischen Schule. Er hat ein Buch geschrieben, Atomkrieg, eine Warnung, das ich vorstellen werde.
Ich bin ja nicht für Atomkrieg, ich bin nur für Atomwaffen.
Genau, genau. Stefan will einen Atomkrieg. Nein, das wollen wir natürlich nicht. Dann, du bist ein Freund von Smart Homes, würdest du am liebsten alles mit dem Smartphone steuern. Die Superreichen sagen jetzt, nee, lieber nicht. Werde ich einen Artikel vorstellen.
Haben wir schon jemals gesagt, dass die Superreichen gute Ideen haben, ihr Leben so führen, wie man es leben sollte?
Nein. Und dann zum Schluss noch ein Musiktipp, Fatma Said, eine großartige Supranistin.
Sehr gut gesungen. Sehr, werde ich natürlich folgen, diese Empfehlung dann. Trumps Zollpolitik. Also wir lesen mehrere Sachen. Steven Myron, der neue CEA, hat eine Rede gehalten am 7. April, also genau zur richtigen Zeit. Janos Varoufakis hat diesen Maralago-Akkord eingeschätzt und in der Zeit tauchten zwei Texte von Heike Buchneiste, die noch mal so Willkür-Fragezeichen gibt. Oder gibt es da eigentlich einen Plan und so? Und danach machen wir was ganz Interessantes. Humann, unser Kumpel Humann, hat einen Instagram-Post gemacht über eine Hartebaffersendung. Und das war der bei ihm erfolgreichste LinkedIn-Post bislang mit 45.000 Impressions und 400 Reaktionen. Und er hat mithilfe von KI eine Auswertung der Argumente, die dort. Und da ich ja auch sehr viel Fernsehen gucke und im Podcast darüber rede, dachte ich mir, das ist ein interessanter Workflow. Vielleicht lässt sich die KI-Hilfe, die man da hat, noch nicht zu verwechseln mit Automatisierung, denn man muss relativ viel zusammenbrumpten und arbeiten, doch nochmal so automatisieren, dass wir dem erfolgreichsten journalistischen Genre, dass wir haben, nämlich die Nachtkritik. Also nachts wird geschrieben, was bei Karamioska gesagt wird, damit die Leute, die es gesehen haben, nochmal sich rückversichern, was habe ich da gestern eigentlich gesehen und die es nicht gesehen haben, nachlesen, was sie verpasst haben, und es hat dann immer 100.000 Klicks und so. Das könnte man ja mal automatisieren. Also nehmen wir uns dieses Beispiel. Dann, wie angekündigt, die Zeit hat diesen Text über höhere Geschwindigkeit beim Konsum von Inhalten aller Art, auch Vorlesungen und so. Und am Ende trage ich dir, also diejenigen, die uns das jetzt hören, sehen natürlich schon in der Liste, um wen es hier geht, aber ich trage dir Zitate aus einem Buch vor und du sagst mir dann, ob dich das interessieren würde. Du bist ja ein großer Marx-Fan. Ich bin ja jetzt nicht unbedingt ein zentraler Marx-Fan, aber ich finde es ja auch alles ganz gut. Und lässt dich Marx eigentlich nochmal in die Gegenwart holen, um mal so richtig ein politisches Sachbuch und so weiter. Und da bin ich gespannt, wie die Reaktionen dann ausfallen. Und dann sage ich dir, wer es geschrieben hat und so. Also es sind keine Marx-Zitate, sondern es sind Zitate aus einem Buch von einer Hardcore-Marxistin, von der ich großer Fan bin. Und in dem Fall glaube ich, so sollte man das anwenden. Und deswegen lassen wir zuerst die Inhalte gewähren und sagen danach, wer das gemacht hat. Sozusagen einfach eine Buchempfehlung überwande.
Wer das alles hören möchte, kann das ganz einfach tun. Nämlich kann man den Salon abonnieren. Ab drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei. Das geht am einfachsten und am besten über Steady. Das bedeutet, man geht auf neuezwanziger.de, findet dort einen goldenen Button, klickt man auf diesen, kommt man zur Steady-Seite und kann ein Abo abschließen. Das günstigste Abo ist drei Euro und dann gibt es noch ein bisschen teure Abos. Die bieten aber in dem Sinne nicht mehr Inhalt, sondern man hat nur dann bei dem ganz teuren Abo nochmal die Möglichkeit, andere mit einzuladen in den Salon. Also wer das machen möchte, kann das natürlich auch sehr gern tun, aber ab drei Euro ist man dabei und kann dann nicht nur diese aktuelle Folge hören, sondern natürlich auch alle Folgen, die wir schon aufgenommen haben. Plus die Live-Salons sind auch da. Das heißt viele, viele Stunden, Gespräche über Bücher vor allem sind es ja und relevante Artikel, die erschienen sind im Monat. Wer jetzt sagt, ich bin bei Apple und will auch eigentlich da bleiben, was macht das?
Darf das.
Darf das und dann?
Der hört ja unseren Podcast eh schon über Apple und dann taucht er in dieser Liste einfach der Salon auf und dann kann er sagen, klick ich an. Der Play-Button ist also ein Buy-Button und dann kauft man für 3,50 Euro oder so. Das ist ein bisschen teuer als bei Steady. Wir bevorzugen ja Steady, weil wir da das ganze Archiv liefern. Da wissen wir, da kommen relativ wenig Nachfragen. Bei Apple ist es einfach, weil man einfach einklickt und dann kann man Salon hören. Oder Patreon, falls ihr schon einen Patreon-Account habt, den nutzen, extra dafür anlegen. Natürlich nicht, da ist dann Steady.
Wunderbar, dann freuen wir uns über neue Abonnenten und freuen uns gleich über Spotify zu diskutieren. Ich habe ja gar keinen Spotify.
Auf Spotify.
Ich habe ja gar keinen Spotify.
Das diskutieren wir gleich aus.
Also, bis gleich.